my name is Peter Parker I'm pretty sure
you know the rest I saved the city fell
in love then I saved the city again and
again and again look I'm a comic book
serial I get a Christmas album and it's
so so popsicle but this isn't about me
not anymore
spider-man swings in once a day zip zap
zop in his little mask and answers to no
one I love you morons dad I love you
Oh God my name is Miles Morales I'm the
one and only spider-man at least that's
what I thought
you have you here for super collider did
all of this
you're like me that's impossible
all right kids listen up this part is
your universe
soggy it's weird it's gross and this
delicious normal fry is my universe so
you want to learn to be spider-man can
you teach me yes I can time to swing
good double tap to release and clip it
out again whip and release your natural
lip hey guys who are you I'm Gwen Stacy
I'm from another another dimension how
many more spotty people are there hey
fellas this could literally not get any
weirder it can get weird okay we need to
get back to our universes soon Brooklyn
is gonna collapse my family lives in
Brooklyn
[Music]
it's mine
if I don't destroy the collider none of
us will have a home to go home soon
remember what makes you different
this wall is what makes you spider-man
officer I love you wait do animals talk
in this dimension cuz I don't want to
freak him out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]